boy is it getting wild over here
we are getting wild
uh yeah throw that out there that's
great that's great uh let me ask you a
question please let me ask you a
question to the people in the audience
okay do you want to be the breadwinner
in your relationship or are you okay
with your significant other making that
bread that's the question of the day
that's the question of the day um oh god
okay well do i ever have to work again
is pretty much your question
well i don't know
is it an ego thing that i need to be the
the breadwinner
if i got a lovely lady to take care of
me while i
bring in the creative juices to our
house you'd be open to that i wouldn't
mind but
i don't want to feel useless okay so
maybe i don't know that's an interesting
question yeah it is and well let's break
down some of the details of the story
because we're going to get into it let's
just get your take on this at some point
oh at the end okay at the end well let's
get into this story right here because i
want to get people's thumbs up if you
want to be the breadwinner so if you
want to be the person making the money
in your household give a thumb up
if you're the person that's like look i
don't care just as long as we got money
in the house i don't care if my wife or
my husband for that matter makes more
than me give a thumb down if you want to
be the number one breadwinner thumb it
up if you're okay with being number two
in your household thumb down can we do
that let's do it okay i'll keep track
all right so okay this is our wild money
move of the week do you want to be the
breadwinner in your relationship or are
you okay with someone else making that
bread so here's the story well
apparently the wild money move is this
uh if you
marry a woman who makes more than you
watch out because women who make more
than their husbands
it doesn't end up pretty here's the
story here according to a university of
chicago study that when women out earn
their husbands the marriages tend to
struggle
marriages with female breadwinners are
50 percent more
likely to end in divorce now here's a
little a funny crazy stat for you not so
funny fun fact if you will
50 of all marriages already end up in
divorce anyway yeah so now you're gonna
add on top of that another 50 percent
that if your wife makes more than you
um that you're gonna end up in divorce
so basically if your wife makes more
than you pack your buddy it's not
gonna work out or get a job get a job
bro anyway this is what's happening
right now this study came out there from
the university of chicago
uh 50 chance if your wife makes more
than you
you will end up
most likely to be divorced yeah okay
what do we got thumbs up thumbs down
what do we got going on we have uh we
have some thumbs we have a lot of thumbs
up we got so people want to make that
money yeah they don't want to be real
john with the two thumbs up know what
thumbs up parker
uh god one thumbs up
uh i got psych sake uh thumbs down okay
and she looks like a lovely woman okay
uh jorge sarah thumbs up both of us get
that dough
thumbs down from jonathan a lot of
thumbs up for john john young john says
if that lady wants to get rid of me and
i ain't making no money then i'm screwed
you're screwed bro anyway the story the
study continues david oh boy so the
study by the american sociological
review shows that when a wife out earns
her husband
he's more likely to cheat
on her
he's more likely to cheat let me break
it down for you
so a study shows that five percent of
men
whose wives out earn them
are likely to cheat five percent so
wives who out earn them
five percent unlikely cheat but here's
where it gets tricky
fifteen percent of men
who were 100 financially dependent on
their wives had affairs so let me break
that down too
so if your wife if your wife makes more
than you
right yeah you're you're
five percent more likely to cheat
right
but if your wife oh my god if you
full-on depend on your wife like you're
the stay-at-home dead yeah
okay your wife's grinding she's working
she's ceoing it up
you're home taking care of the kids
cooking yeah you're three times more
likely to cheat dude and not even ceoing
it up like she's working two jobs and
you're at home doing nothing and you
still cheat on her damn what a loser
dude you're a dick yeah you're an
now you do you end up cheating
you get caught
you're broke now you're homeless now you
gotta go work it's not a good luck to
cheat on your successful wife don't
recommend i don't recommend cheating on
your wife in general hello not a good
idea but especially when you don't got
no jobs if she's taking care of you dude
yeah it's well here's the reason
people out there must be like well why
is this yeah like break this like give
me something don't just end there yeah
here's we go
the biggest reason for the tension in
the relationship aside from the large
gaps in income obviously right all
revolve around the deep-seated ideas
about gender roles
and societal expectations
about men
okay yeah so basically men should be
working exactly men should be bringing
home the bacon women
women want a provider women you know
stay in the kitchen you know men work
you know that whole
old school mentality which i think these
days
is kind of f and bs yeah i think more
women are entering the workforce they
want to work right i think more women
are becoming ceos i think yeah i think
look you know
they want to work they've been working
they've been working women just want to
be taking justice we want to be paid the
same amount equal equal pay for equal
work yeah and meanwhile
homie over here is cheating on you while
you're hurting while you're working dude
we just did pat just did an interview
with dr warren farrell he wrote the boy
crack crisis and now this he talks about
that he talks about women that they want
a provider they as soon as like the man
becomes
kind of acting like a like a woman like
a subconscious like a
uh when they see that they married a big
they they're out they're just like this
isn't cool so of course so not only this
article shouldn't be taken as like a
woman wants to be in the kitchen while
man provides it's like i wanna yeah be
ceo i don't wanna take care of some dude
yeah like the dude should be ceo with me
at some other company like power couple
yeah oh i like that power couple well
speaking of power couples
do you have another point well no well
yeah of course dude if you're if you're
not in that power couple if your wife is
taking care of you
and you're cheating on her what the hell
are you doing what the hell are you
doing bro what's wrong with you yeah
because it's because they are
emasculated that's what it comes down to
these societal expectations
i'm the guy i stay at home my wife works
it's just not normal so you know when
things aren't normal you have an adverse
reaction to that so
look i don't know if this is bs if this
is crazy stuff or this is actually legit
um would love to know in the comments
but here's here's the silver lining to
all this right because you don't need to
fall victim to the odds here you could
actually do something about this okay so
we all know that money is a taboo
subject you know people don't typically
talk about it
um especially after you hear a story
like this you're like oh my god
[Music]
the most important things that you can
be on the same page in your relationship
are money
clearly people fight about money
and communication communication is key
if you talk to any old couple out there
right and you say how do you make the
marriage work what is it what is it we
communicate
we talk it out yeah you don't you don't
just keep things under wraps and you
know bury it down deep below
you talk it out yeah
it's
for sure
a recipe for success communicating it's
one of the hardest things that uh to do
sometimes to communicate and
like be like completely transparent
about things but it's the key that's the
key that reminds me of a dane cook joke
from vicious circle a dane cook
reference ladies and gentlemen go ahead
he's like this beautiful old couple
married for 70 years and i approached
the the gentleman i'm like hey you know
i want this what's the secret to being
in a marriage like this and the old man
looks at me and he gets he pulls me in
closer and he goes
cheat
[Laughter]
what
cheat you have to cheat that's his
advice yeah well
clearly he's on the 15 out of things
yeah definitely women control the
narrative
um well i think look teamwork makes a
dream work communicate right
yeah discuss where you what the good the
bad the ugly your shared vision your
shared dreams how do the relationship
can improve what are the problems are
look honey baby look things aren't
working out over here i really need your
help with this i don't like when you do
this i love when you do this communicate
okay especially if you're in a marriage
um because the whole goal of the
marriage is the whole
live happily ever after right right
but uh
if you seriously have a problem with
your wife making more money than you you
should probably bring it up she might be
like all right well you know how about i
stay home and you go work home well yeah
no that's not even like bring it up it's
just like get your together bro
maybe like i don't know well make more
money like i don't want to make it seem
like the guy is a complete loser because
maybe the women just has a great career
she's done a great job that's a good
point the guy has maybe a flexible
schedule he can stay at home more it's
not like winner and loser
right it's not so much that so you have
because even think about it when the man
is the breadwinner the woman's not a
loser because she's not she's taking
care of the kids
it's societal norms and stereotypes
but for the man to be staying at home
taking care of the kids doing the
carpool yeah it's it's not normal it's
abnormal it's not traditional
and that's even more reason to talk it
out yeah exactly and if you are at that
point of like i'm not that i'm a total
loser she's just a you know she's a
brilliant freaking g she's a lawyer
she's a doctor she's whatever you have
to be able to provide the same amount of
value into the relationship by doing
other things dude like look out for her
do things that she can't do because
she's making that money you know hear
her out make her dinner do things like
where you also balance scales the bottom
line is if you have a successful wife
yeah appreciate that yeah if you're a
badass person table's turned if you have
a successful husband i appreciate that
one thing that i like about uh pat's
other company php are the couples that
work together yeah and you see these
power couples
dominate the sapalas right
um
ricky and erica guyton right but the
list goes on apollos um
what's my guy um hector hector and erica
but they're um you know brother and
sister or um rodolfo and sassy like
these people
t-rex of course my guy but power couples
and uh it is extremely effective so
supporting your running mate
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken